in fact, therefore, a certain number of
visits to the industrial sites and
laboratories with which we have
contracted so today
it is the racing site therefore for the
company father bintec so I will see
how things are going
I will  ensure with the
management team that the lille ie the
production capacity is indeed in line
with what we expect since we
expect a certain number of backs
now every week to
check very precisely and then
my sweat  and also the way in
which supplies are going because
we have a lot of factory workers now that
they are working to increase
production capacity on the
European continent,
obviously we have to check that there is
no break in order to make a  vaccine it
takes four to five hundred components so
we will discuss all that here thank you
at the end of the queue
oh
cheers
[Music]
the other
is what we have
everything at p g
j  I think
with access
the body can
rise enough to be resolved
[Music]
the extremely important technical issue be
careful, however,
handling the temperature must obviously remain
unless you have to segré
permanently
ok absolutely no problem  lasts
obviously
the safety of the vaccine or the most
talked about in humor is now
off been a little bit welcome
die welt
de gaulle maluleke thompson cole
speed of paimpol you believed with thank you
for being the politician and our problems that
means that  there they are now
formed not stored for three
weeks finally if we can be in
each of 13 of his boxes there are
some samples that are taken
they will then be sent to the
testing locations showing week to
test and when
we are sure that
the  zero defects at that time the doses
of vaccine ready to send then
everywhere in europe
so much
the better the opposite
then our important and that suddenly
trai  l funès jean multi in
the buyer
but from there to
2 dry ice there is now the
temperature in less than 15 of mourning
it allows to keep for
ten days so you have to
call I am often told looted media
the  greece is currently being discussed
ababy
just now
this package the mainland and skated 6000
people so it is europe that
organized later to mélanie d
m
yes
[Music]